first of all it has been four years now  almost four yrs since I was first ten  times we define prison without charge  and has been now two years since I was  granted political asylum in there all  that time nearly four years I've not  been charged with a fence in nineteen  them orange women and there has been no  public document  relation to my work the United States  how can it be that such situation in  Europe horizons square person is held  and for you- is restricted and they are  kept from their family while the pace  for annulment united states do they ever  larger case against that person and  their organizations europe is meant to  be a place where the rule or respected  where basic rights are respected somehow  in a situation has developed spirit for  me but also some ovens  where basic rights if we have previously  it will previously universally accepted  in Europe uh no longer respected through